[Music]
as a two-time major winner and a major
mvp olofmeister has accomplished what
most cs go players can only dream of the
first team to win a second championship
here on global offensive phenol of weiss
is playing it so safely they know that
they have it exist gets one and he's
back on it he's got the kid he's holding
it down i'm not sure there's enough time
throughout his career he's been a
crucial part of some iconic plays
the defuse is coming in he's still going
oh
just about gets it and some
controversial ones he sees them down
there straight headshot they have no
idea
smith's looking confused and dazed and
there's gonna be a follow-up shot
over the past few years olofmeister has
been trying to step away from the game
taking multiple breaks due to health and
motivation issues but even though he
keeps trying to leave there's always
something that pulls him back in grim
peeks out and dies to him fallen drops
his shot and olof is looking good are we
seeing the end of olaf's legendary
career
or is he just getting started
eliminating gambit in the quarter finals
it's absolutely
unbelievable fun and games
you just can't take the lan out of face
clan
olofmeister is one of the most
successful cs go players of all time but
things have changed a lot since his
glory days ladies and gentlemen
your esl one cavalier champions are
fanatic
after leaving fnatic at the end of 2017
he joined faze clan to form csgo's first
international super team all in one
position and guardian makes it just nice
to find the flash
and nikko fittingly gets the last kill
his face dominate new york in 2017 in
the barclays center all the way through
this tournament but despite a strong
start the team failed to live up to
expectations when it mattered most
guardian waits
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh this happens they
made work clown nine are your alien
major champions
following the heartbreak of phase clan's
boston major loss and the poor results
that followed olaf decided to take a
personal leave of absence in april 2018.
aside from a short break back in 2016
olaf had been playing pro cs non-stop
for six years and it was starting to
take a toll on his health when i played
like at the meter it
was kind of locking in the arm like felt
like cramps and locking and then we
would jump from different place and
right now that's all gone pretty much
everyone agreed that he deserved a break
but no one really expected it and while
olaf watched from the sidelines faze
lifted the iem sydney trophy with his
substitute
exist astralis are running out players
options and time it exists and guardians
are doing it's faze clan
just a few weeks after faze's win in
australia olaf announced his return to
competitive play originally he planned
to return in time for the ecs season 5
finals but on june 5th he released a new
statement saying that he wasn't ready to
come back just yet without olaf faze
went on to place fourth at that
tournament he didn't go around towards
squad this could cost in the round but
fully hit the drop oh my god it's coming
down to the last few seconds and device
closes it out with the ak and while the
team did go on to win a few small time
events things just weren't the same
without him but then in july 2018 four
months after his leave started the fans
finally got what they wanted olaf was
back
faze thanked croman for his brief
service and announced that olaf would
finally be returning to the starting
lineup ahead of ely premier 2018.
unfortunately olaf's debut didn't
exactly go as planned faze bombed out of
elig without winning a single match he's
dancing nico sees him can he get the
kill though finally he goes down but
that's nico alone again it's down to
nico exist moving in and that's going to
be that at the very end
16 to 14 for fnatic unreal game of
counter strike and fazer out but olaf
wasn't about to let the loss get to him
faze clan i mean what they've done here
in miami it's absolutely off the charts
16 12 and they take the victory here at
the grand finals unbelievable play
over the next two years phase one
epicenter e-league and blast but still a
major title eluded them after a slew of
roster changes olaf was now the oldest
player on faze clan and he was losing
motivation to carry on with the new team
so in may 2020 oauth decided to take
another break given his declining
performance and the constant breaks some
members of the community began to
question if he'd return at all and if he
did would it even be with phase this is
his third break right and he's always
been back within like a couple of months
or three months or something last time
when you took that break two years ago
he was back within three months same way
when he had that injury he was back
within two months and always he came
back like in decent form so i don't see
why he wouldn't but faze had to move on
they added care by hoping the former
major mvp could bring them back to their
glory days now all on to valder the
brave viking that can he's tucked into
gandalf
and it does look magical nico would need
the wall bang he's jiggling he's jiggly
he's wasting time nico hits the shot has
he got it
dude he's in the chat and he's done it
3-0 faze clan take a trophy and it's in
three no less an untarnished record but
once the honeymoon period with kirby was
over thieves began to struggle once
again incendiaries kind of make them a
bit uncomfortable coldzera oh my he's
able to flick back in time and then
kirby's supposed to come off barrels but
he gets denied by knock rez through the
edge of the wall takes the man advantage
this could be it rain at bat 1v3 little
hp to work with and a bomb plant to make
it worse the flash is fantastic
and in october 2020 things went from bad
to worse for faze nico was out and with
just one day to find a replacement ahead
of the blast premiere fall season there
was only one man who could save faze
clan
olofmeister an adjustment here from ibr
they're actually going to turn it back
to ramp olaf meister fully aware of the
situation
with a nice clean angle 2k spray down
leaving kng alone faze didn't end up
qualifying for the blast premiere finals
but they did show that they could still
go toe-to-toe with some of the best
teams in the world and with olofmeister
rushed back into the roster analysts did
expect some growing pains i think if you
ask the bass players and if they answer
truthfully the amount of practice
they've had coming into this tournament
with this lineup with all of my stuff is
probably very very limited compared to
mibr who's been playing tournaments
after tournaments but olaf wasn't
struggling with a piece of pro play like
many expected for someone who hadn't
competed in nearly five months he looked
solid
oh but brokey he does slip into the ct
spawn these other two were on display
olaf good position and a second grim
peeks out and dies to him fallen drops
his shot and olaf is looking good three
kills
how do you think it's possible that he
basically just comes in and has such a
massive performance when he himself
isn't even sure of his future how is it
that he can actually do that right now
and destroy people nobody should write
olive off no matter what time it is a
big talent in the game he's been at the
top for a very long time and he's been
the best player in the world i don't
think even if he takes a couple years
break he's still gonna come back to the
server and do good things so there's no
surprise to me that he's playing really
good after a few months though the
results still weren't coming and olaf
was back to thinking about retirement
i've been playing this game for so long
i know like ups and downs will come but
um
i still think i want to take a break
like i don't know
it was supposed to be a long break for
me to just think about everything and
regain motivation all this stuff but um
the guys needed help and i mean i i
think i i owe it to them to help them as
much as i can
[Music]
he has a kit and he has a smoke and olaf
has to leave now he's gonna make a bunch
of noise he's gonna get that kill he's
gonna put the smoke on top of bomb and
no not like this you are kidding me
navi finish like this
finally in february 2021 olofmeister
made the decision to step away once more
and this time it was going to be
permanent but then in june faith clan's
igl coldzera benched himself after a
string of poor results and rumors began
to circulate that olaf was back to
practicing with the team
i think there was rumors that olaf was
uh playing with them do you think that's
where they'll end up do you think
they'll get olaf
absolutely yes yeah okay why no it's
obvious it's obvious because i think if
they have no options they will not pick
some uh
young and experienced player olaf is a
legendary player and often feels beyond
criticism but even his fans weren't
expecting much from him after a four
month break jack's trying to hold on and
actually doing a pretty good job here he
goes up one more head shot he maybe
could have had it he had the chance he's
turned it into a one versus one
absolutely out of nowhere and niko
sneaked it up behind his got the kill i
don't think all of meister has any clue
he doesn't know that nico's right he's
gonna walk into the shot and he still
brings him down with a headshot olaf
saving the day for phase tapping the
bomb trying to fake it out and that was
the right idea but it doesn't matter all
of mice are showing up quad kill at the
end to close the halfway what a
performance from the returned legend
olaf showed up at blast and proved that
he still had what it took to be a top
tier competitor and at iem cologne faze
upset gambit in the quarter finals to
secure a top four finish exile all the
frags he's had this tournament these are
compulsory for gambit
evades the flash multiple targets
carrick's flipped the net though and
he's caught on the mantle interest
doesn't have the health for this one hp
faze clan have done it eliminating
gambit in the quarter finals it's
absolutely unbelievable fun and games
you just can't take the lan out of phase
clan
[Music]
since his impressive run in cologne olaf
has continued to perform for faze and
although it's possible he takes another
break or even retires he's proven that
he never lets his team or his fans down
he's the old guy who still has it an
incredible player who always manages to
come back in at just the right time and
pick up right where he left off
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages